proteins play countless roles throughout
the biological world some transport
nutrients throughout the body some help
chemical reactions to happen at faster
rates others build the structures that
make up living things
despite this wide range of functions all
proteins are made out of the same 21
building blocks called amino acids amino
acids are made of carbon oxygen nitrogen
and hydrogen atoms and some contain
sulfur atoms Celino cysteine is the only
standard amino acid that contains a
selenium atom
these atoms form an amino group a
carboxyl group and a sidechain all
attached to a central carbon atom the
sidechain determines an amino acids
properties and is the only part that
varies from amino acid to amino acid
[Music]
hydrophobic amino acids have carbon-rich
side chains which don't interact well
with water hydrophilic or polar amino
acids interact well with water charged
amino acids interact with oppositely
charged amino acids or with other
molecules
primary structure the primary structure
of a protein is the linear sequence of
amino acids as included by DNA the amino
acids in a protein are joined by peptide
bonds which linked the amino group of
one amino acid to the carboxyl group of
another a water molecules released each
time a peptide bond is formed this
linked series of carbon nitrogen and
oxygen atoms is the protein backbone
book team chains often fold into two
types of secondary structures alpha
helixes and beta sheets an alpha helix
is a right-handed coil stabilized by
hydrogen bonds between the amine and
carboxyl groups of nearby
amino acids beta sheets are formed when
hydrogen bonds stabilize two or more
adjacent strands of amino acids the
tertiary structure of a protein is the
three-dimensional shape of the protein
chain the shape is determined by the
characteristics of the amino acids
making up the chain many proteins form
globular shapes with hydrophobic side
chains sheltered on the inside away from
surrounding water molecules membrane
bound proteins have hydrophobic amino
acids clustered together on their
exteriors so that hydrophobic side
chains can interact with the lipids in
the membrane charged amino acids allow
proteins to interact with molecules that
have complementary charges
[Music]
the functions of many proteins rely upon
their three-dimensional shapes for
example hemoglobin forms a pocket to
hold heme a small molecule with an iron
atom in the center that binds to oxygen
quaternary structure two or more
polypeptide chains can come together to
form one functional molecule with
several subunits the four subunits of
hemoglobin cooperates so the complex can
more easily pick up oxygen in the lungs
and release it in the body different
visual representations of proteins can
give us visual clues about protein
structure and function this
space-filling diagram shows all of the
atoms that make up this protein this
representation called a ribbon or
cartoon diagram shows the organization
of the protein backbone and highlights
alpha helixes this surface
representation shows the areas on the
protein that are accessible to water
molecules most proteins are smaller than
the wavelength of light for example the
hemoglobin molecule is about 6.5
nanometers in size hemoglobin is found
in high concentration in red blood cells
a typical red blood cell contains about
280 million hemoglobin molecules
the three-dimensional shapes of proteins
determine their function
the flexible arms of antibodies protect
us from disease by recognizing and
binding to pathogens and targeting them
for destruction by the immune system
[Music]
the hormone insulin is a small stable
protein that can easily maintain its
shape while traveling through the blood
to regulate blood glucose level
alpha-amylase is an enzyme that begins
digestion of starches in our saliva
[Music]
the calcium pump is aided by magnesium
and powered by ATP to move calcium ions
back to the sarcoplasmic reticulum after
each muscle contraction ferritin is a
spherical protein with channels that
allow iron atoms to enter in eggs
depending upon an organisms needs on the
inside ferritin forms a hollow space
with iron atoms attached to the inner
wall ferritin stores iron in a non-toxic
form
collagen forms a strong triple helix
that is used throughout the body for
structural support collagen molecules
can form elongated fibrils
which aggregate to form collagen fibers
this type of collagen is abundant in
skin and tendons learn more about the
functions and 3d structures of proteins
and other molecular machines at the rcsb
protein databank
[Music]
you